today we're starting a new thinker and a
new work a very early work of this
existentialist thinker albert camus
we're looking at his essay a very long
essay actually as it turns out
the myth of syphilis oftentimes it's
anthologized
and they only give you a little bit of
it
what i'm going to do is take several
lectures to actually go through the
whole of it because it's a very
important piece
for understanding existentialism not
only be because it shows you camus early
attitude towards things
you could pair this up in part with some
of his his fictional works
but also because he's reflecting on
other existentialists this is in some
ways as far as the movement goes a late
piece
so he'll discuss
retrospectively
and also critically
how their attitudes towards life
death
meaning
human nature all those those sorts of
grand themes how they come together
whether they're adequate
i want to begin with this
camus distinguishes between what he
calls an absurd sensitivity that can be
found widespread in the age
and
an absurd philosophy which in art which
our time properly speaking has not known
his job as he feels it is to articulate
that absurd philosophy
and this is a little bit different than
some of the other existentialists that
he's going to take issue with we're
going to see so he thinks that we
inhabit a time
remember he is writing
you know mid-century last century a lot
of things have taken place
there's been a sort of general eclipse
of reason or rationality
understood in many ways
philosophy has had plenty of time to
you might say both turn itself inward
and look at individual experience and
start focusing on existential conditions
and also to see that the pretenses that
were made earlier of this being you know
the best of all possible worlds
a time of continual progress all those
had sort of you know fallen by the
wayside by the time of world war one the
great uh catastrophe that that entailed
and the subsequent you know
economic
dislocations the grand hopes that were
raised during those times and then
crushed in many ways
seeing
movements originally aimed at some sort
of radical reform and reworking of human
nature turned just as totalitarian
and
dangerous as any other ones and then
also seeing the rise of in response to
that of fascism a whole another thing
add to that just the day-to-day
you know thinking about the world which
never has fully made sense anyway
under any lens perfectly
and you have a good mix for a time in
which the absurd
becomes a preoccupation
so camus is focusing on that
and
he says one thing that you can
distinguish from the beginning is
whether you take the absurd as a
starting point or whether you reach it
as a conclusion
of your
philosophical or
semi-philosophical investigation some
sort of exercise of reason which is
trying to make sense of things
and
he also says another thing later on and
i wanted to bring this up right away
another distinction is whether we're
talking about the experience or the
feeling of the absurd that's one thing
or whether we're talking about the
notion or the concept something a bit
more articulate a bit more explicit a
bit more
intellectual
these two inform each other of course
but we want to distinguish between a
sort of general
big picture
broad environmental
sense of the absurd
and then being able to look at the
absurd with the mind's eye
but the absurd is what he is going to
take is his focal point
he's going to address the thought of
some existentialist thinkers and i put a
lot of stuff over here on the board as
well
that's one of the beauties of this essay
as far as i'm concerned is that he's
actually addressing a whole range of
people who are part of the canon of the
same movement that he gets associated
with
but which he's in some ways
uncomfortable with
and you know he's going to differ from
sartre he's not going to talk about sart
in this essay he will break with sartre
about other things later on here he's
concerned with kierkegaard
with
heidegger to a little extent with carly
ospers a little bit more with a guy
who's not very well known but but
deserves to be
leon shestov
and with a few other thinkers as well
also with some thinkers who don't fit
into existentialism per se but are
associated with it in continental
philosophy like who's role
and he also mentions mock shaler
now he sees them as making an advance
on other thought and attitudes
in the 20th century well even in the
19th century we want to talk about
kierkegaard nietzsche all you also
mentioned nietzsche and dostoyevsky
if we want to talk about them
they're making an advance
and yet at the same time
they're
going astray they're not
actually lingering with the absurd as
such they're they're engaging the absurd
in a way that
other people are failing to do so
but then they're having a kind of
losing their nerve their
they're not following through kamu
thinks on on the consequences the
intellectual the the relational
even the
in some way physical consequences of
living an absurd life
so we'll get to that in a moment
where does he begin this essay
he starts this very famously by saying
there is only one truly serious there's
only one truly serious philosophical
problem
and that's suicide
so that's an interesting way to start
it's very unusual to to begin
even a piece of moral philosophy and
this is this is in large part you know
if you had to decide where you're going
to put this
in the traditional boundaries of
philosophy where would you put this it's
not epistemology
it's more
in some ways metaphysics
moral philosophy
it's not aesthetics really
it's not political philosophy yet
maybe philosophy of human nature
so he's already preoccupied with with
moral questions and we're going to see
him working out something like an ethics
in a little while
but when you do something like that do
you begin with a single issue not
usually you begin with some principles
you say something like
the only thing that matters is the good
will
or what is happiness here's some views
and this is probably the best view
or
mankind is uh totally in the thrall is
paraphrasing of course totally in the
thrall of two masters pain and pleasure
and everything else boils into that you
start out with general principles
usually
and then you start talking about things
like well is suicide justified
or is euthanasia justified or how should
we deal with world hunger things like
that
so kami was privileging a particular
problem
as the philosophical question to begin
with
that's an interesting take to start with
i mean if you were going to privilege
some other philosophical question as do
you want to start with
it might be something like
what am i what kind of life should i
live
how can i come to know myself
um you know what really gets people
started with philosophy
is
this sometimes like aristotle says in
wonder
you encounter something that makes you
marvel but quite often what gets people
started is a preoccupation with some
actual real tangible existential problem
so he's going to start with suicide and
where is he going to be headed with this
ultimately it's towards three
consequences my revolt my freedom my
passion he says
so let's look at this philosophical
problem of suicide first
he says that the learned and classical
dialectic must yield to a more modest
attitude of mind deriving at one at the
same time from common sense and
understanding that's his beginning place
he doesn't you'll notice he's not
quoting an awful lot of other
philosophers in this
he wants to try to begin from our
experience
so he's empirical in that sense
and he says we're concerned here at the
outset with the relationship between
individual thought and suicide
an act like this an act like suicide is
prepared in the silence of the heart as
is a great work of art the man himself
is ignorant of it the person who's going
to commit suicide
that he's saying
is
not necessarily ignorant of the fact
that they're going to commit suicide but
they're not aware of everything that's
going on within them ultimately
impelling them towards that
and he says something more broad he says
beginning to think
is beginning to be undermined
beginning to think about things
not in a narrow sense
but in a broader sense sometimes if you
wanted to use a metaphor with this
not just what you're focusing on
directly but the things that you also
see out of the corners of your eyes and
the things that you're you're aware of
that sort of awareness is to begin to be
undermined the things that you believe
in the things you're taking as solid as
real
start to become
ephemeral
or unstable or less reliable than you
would suppose
he says society has but little
connection with such beginnings the worm
is in man's heart it's part of our human
nature
this is where it must be sought
so um
how does this work he says
living is never easy
you continue making the gestures
commanded by existence for many reasons
the first of which is habit and you know
if again if you think about this what is
90 to 99 of our life
it's going through and doing the sort of
things that we do without particularly
thinking about it i use this example
many times in class when i ask my
students
not for this but when i'm teaching about
other things i'm talking about the force
of habit and our means and our ends i
asked them how they got themselves to
the classroom did they actually have to
think about what to do once their alarm
went off and they got themselves out of
bed did they have to you know if they
were going to take a shower did they
have to go to the shower nozzle and
figure out how that works and what the
optimal way of doing it was no you do
these things by habit
that anybody actually sit down and ask
themselves what am i doing by going to
this class
is this part of my my grand scheme of
life no you just go to class because
you're a student and that's what you do
and that's the way many of us are
most of the time
even those who are doing philosophy
and are really doing it right
they're not just you know quibbling
about arguments or doing you know purely
historical investigations but thinking
about life
even they are only doing it a portion of
the time
so he says you continue making the
gestures commanded by existence for many
reasons the first of which is habit
dying voluntarily implies that you have
recognized even instinctively the
ridiculous character of that habit
the absence of any profound reason for
living
the insane character of that daily
agitation and the uselessness of
suffering so when a person kills
themselves
and this is a very big problem actually
in
you know um
20th century france um
i mean durkheim actually wrote and wrote
a piece on it because he was interested
in why
people kill themselves you could look at
it statistically
and there were enough statistics to go
by
why does a person kill themselves
life has in a certain sense lost its its
fundamental moorings it doesn't mean
that there are no meanings but there are
no meanings that are supported by deeper
meanings you might
say so he says there's a feeling of
absurdity
that that arises
and he says a world that can be
explained even with bad reasons is a
familiar world
this is an important
concept
camus is going to stress over and over
again the difference between the
unfamiliar
and the familiar what we're at home with
what we can make sense out of what is to
our size you might say and then the the
rest
a world that can be explained even with
bad reasons is a familiar world but on
the other hand in a universe suddenly
divested of illusions and lights
man feels an alien a stranger his exile
is without remedy because he's deprived
of the memory of a lost home or the hope
of a promised land this divorce between
a man and his life the actor in a
setting
is properly the feeling of absurdity so
when we have this sense of absurdity
when we're grasping the absurd
what we're realizing is that things are
not as they typically seem to us
we've been making all sorts of
assumptions we've been living with
illusions and
those can't really be
i mean they can be justified in one
sense we need them to keep on living but
you know you can ask yourself well why
keep on with that and if you go down to
that foundation there's there's nothing
there to support it he'd say
um
and so he lays out the fundamental
problem of this this entire work
and here you see that even though
camus is
quite often saying things like i don't
have an ethic
there are no values or norms by which i
guide myself and that's one way people
understand existentialism there is a
norm there for him
it says for a man who does not cheat
what he believes to be what he believes
to be true must determine his action
so there's a demand for consistency for
following through for
if even if the rest of the universe
doesn't make sense at least in my action
and my willing i can make that make
sense
you see this not only in camus you see
this also in jean-paul sartre
existentialism is a
humanism and also in being in
nothingness
and in other essays and you also see
this in uh simone de bevoir this sense
that even if you strip everything else
away there is at least this possibility
of consistency
of following through on one's thoughts
so he says
belief in the absurdity of existence
must then determine his conduct so if
you actually accept this notion of the
absurd
then you have to follow it through and
you'll be tempted to go off in this
direction and go off in this direction
and not stick to it
and he says i'm speaking of course with
men inclined to be in harmony with
themselves
and now he asks so does the absurd
dictate death
is there a logic to the point of death
he says i cannot know unless i pursue
without reckless passion in the sole
light of evidence so i'm thinking this
through not just relying on feelings
the reasoning of which i am here
suggesting the source
this is what i call an absurd reasoning
many have begun it i do not yet know
whether or not they kept to it so we're
going to look at some people and see
whether
their ways of becoming aware of the
absurd and then following through on
what it would mean
the meaninglessness of what it would
mean you could say if you want to joke
around
whether they have stayed consistent to
it or not
and now he says something very
interesting as well
the problem is not so simple as yes and
no and you know if you think about this
when you have a problem
or a question
quite often we want to say well you know
there's two ways you can go
and if the problem here is suicide
you either kill yourself or you don't
right
i mean that's i mean you could say while
you try to kill yourself you know don't
succeed maybe that's somewhere in
between here
even if you're actually really trying to
kill yourself and somebody prevents you
from it that's not your fault right
of course you know there's all sorts of
people who you know cut their wrists
this way rather than this way and by now
we're all i think if we watch movies
fairly conscious that there's you know
differences between that
it's not so simple as this though kamina
says
he says there's there's contradictions
between
our opinions and our actions allowance
must be made for those who without
concluding continue questioning
so another possibility
is to neither
take neither poll and at least for the
moment that means accepting no but
that's not a definitive note
that's saying i'm not going to kill
myself now
life has enough meaning for me to make
it through this day or this week or this
month
but if things changed if they you know
life lost enough of the provisional
meaning that it possesses
then i'll do it
or maybe i'll think about it later
or maybe here's another possibility i'm
so busy i can't be bothered with it
right now
he says i also noticed that those who
answered no
act as if they thought yes
that's that's very interesting
there are some people who say no to
killing themselves
but they also
do things
that show you that they don't value
their own their own existence
and he says as a matter of fact if i
accept the nietzschean criterion they
think yes in one way or or another
they're life denying
he says on the other hand it often
happens that those who commit suicide
were assured of the meaning of life
so
some people actually do
say yes but it's not because
life possessed no meaning for them
it's because they lost
a great example of this in roman times
um
if you had a power struggle
and your side lost
well you killed yourself
and it wasn't you know uh saying screw
you to the universe or something like
that i mean this was done by people who
was advised actually by some people who
seem to really have it together
it was the realization that now
my side lost i there's nothing i can do
now and i can kill myself or i can wait
for them to come and kill me
that's a bit different
um
now he says two things that do keep many
people going
so that they say no to suicide even
though they might you know tend towards
it the body he says in a man's
attachment to life there's something
stronger than all the ills in the world
the body's judgment is as good as the
minds and the body shrinks from
annihilation we get into the habit of
living before acquiring the habit of
thinking
another thing is hope now this is an
important theme for this essay because
camus is going to say we should live
without hope
but
hope
can lead people to
keep going in a
very by their experience absurd
existence
he says another life
one must deserve would give you hope or
trickery of those who live not for life
itself but for some great idea that will
transcend it refine it giving it give it
a meaning
uh betray it
so you know if for example a person is a
committed christian or a committed
muslim or if a person
is committed to some
political doctrine that that's not just
you know about managing city affairs or
something or gaining power but something
really big picture
somebody's a committed communist and and
wants to work for the liberation of all
the proletariat worldwide and ending
human suffering where somebody
is
a radical transhumanist
there's a lot of different varieties out
there if there's some sort of ideal that
you have that could motivate you then
then you can go out living even when
things seem to be
absurd
um he's got a great passage about
feeling passion and reality he says like
great works deep feelings always mean
more than they're conscious of saying
the regularity of an impulse a repulsion
in a soul is encountered again in habits
of doing or thinking
is reproduced in consequences of which
the soul itself knows nothing great
feelings take with them their own
universe
splendid or object
they light up with their passion an
exclusive world in which they recognize
their climate
there is a universe of jealousy
of ambition
of selfishness or of generosity
a universe in other words a metaphysics
and an attitude of mind what is true of
already specialized feelings will be
even more so of emotions basically as
indeterminate simultaneously as vague
and as definite as remote and as present
as those furnished us by beauty or
aroused by absurdity
now what's the connection between that
and what we were just talking about
suicide
well
i mean you can have a great ideal that
motivates you
that's intellectual essentially i mean
it ties in with your the
his roots in your soul or your
personality or your heart but it is
primarily something you can cognize
and then there's affectivity then there
is mood feeling passion
desire
and the world is very different to the
person who's motivated primarily by this
feeling think about the way the world is
to someone who is inhabited
by and guided by joy
or gratitude as compared to the person
who is motivated primarily by jealousy
and the need to compare constantly to
others
or the person who is
melancholic or depressed or
sad all the time
or the person who is constantly seeking
excitement
alternating between excitement and
boredom
these are very different modes of being
in the world
and absurdity itself
camus says can become one of those
feelings
so what is the feeling of absurdity
this is very interesting so now we make
a transition here
and this is a good spot to
put a little bit of other things up on
the board
absurd
how do we encounter
well before we talk about that let's
talk about um
whether we can keep it in check
camus says that the feeling of absurdity
cannot be contained
and it cannot be predicted and you can't
make it you that means that you also
cannot
automatically produce it if you were
say an
evangelist of existentialism if there is
such a thing
and you wanted to try to produce the
feeling of absurdity in some people
let's say you were a professor teaching
an existentialism course and you want to
make your students
feel the full weight of absurdity
you can't do that either
it's not something manageable it's it by
its very nature it eludes and escapes
our
attempts to do that sort of thing he but
he says
at any street corner the feeling of
absurdity can strike any man in the face
as it is in its distressing nudity in
its light without alfulgence it is
elusive beautiful phrase right there
light without effulgence it lights
things up but does not actually cast
illumination on them
he says in any given human being
whatever we may know about that person
or practically be able to deal with
there's always sides there's dimensions
to them that escape us and this not only
applies to human beings other human
beings out there
even those as close to us as our
children our parents our brothers
sisters
our other family
our close friends our enemies we think
we may know inside and out
many of these these people it also
applies to ourselves
we can't fully predict our own selves
and it applies to the world itself
there's always sides to it we're missing
uh he talks about
with respect to ourselves a lower key of
feelings
inaccessible in the heart but partially
disclosed by the acts they imply
and the attitudes of mind
they assume
so even our own
feelings most of our feelings we feel
and we're conscious of feeling them but
there are some feelings
that we may not be entirely aware of and
you know if you think about just to
dwell on this a bit if you think about
some of the basic assumptions of not
just psychoanalysis but you know plenty
of other types of psychotherapy
the idea is that we have motives and
affects that are not fully conscious but
are operative within us as subjects not
necessarily as conscious egos
but as subjects as agencies and that
these drive us
if you want to understand
how somebody
who's being driven by unconscious
motives actually feels about things
now there are techniques to you know
bring this to life partially
i'm not going to talk about those what
i'm talking about here is how can we
develop consciousness of that one way is
by observation you actually look at what
a person does do
and the way not just the things that
they say but the way they say things the
context in which they do it and you can
actually start telling something about
their desires about their loves their
hates their fears their hopes
and you can do this with yourself too
this is part of self-knowledge this has
been running through
um
it's been running through moral
philosophy since the time of the ancient
greeks paying close attention to what it
is that you actually do and what that
reveals not only about what you think
but how you feel
and then it became even more intensified
with christian thinkers particularly you
know the desert monks people like st
augustine
this sort of self scrutiny and analysis
so we have this deeper level of
feelings
now camus says we can actually analyze
absurdity in different spheres
and the ones that he mentions at that
point
so we have the the
we have this sort of day-to-day
let's call it anywhere
but then there's some some more specific
things
it says intelligence
the art of living which
let's just call it what it is
call a spade a spade
turn the card over for what it truly is
this is kamu's ethic
um he's not going to call it such he's
going to you know deny that he has
nothing but this is really
is that
and um also in artwork
he says art and by that we should thank
art
production
and to a lesser extent also
consumption
and
this is what the bulk of the methyl
synthesis the the essay
before we you know finally get to the
the part you know synthesis we must
imagine him happy which we're going to
get to in a long ways from here
this is what the bulk of it is it's
analysis of
how the absurd plays itself out in these
different domains
um before we get to that let's think
about the absurd in in general
um
anywhere in general
he talks about these as involving themes
that run through all literatures and all
philosophies
everyday conversation as well
vectors of experience through which if
we're paying attention we can encounter
the absurd now you know we may encounter
it and then we may
be given some resources by which to try
to banish it and say no
things aren't really absurd
our culture may afford us those we may
have forged them ourselves but camus
thinks that that's really a kappa
let's think about
things that reveal to us uncertainty at
least come to this version of it
so there's deeds
thoughts
even the great ones he says
where do they come from
do they always come from great
beginnings
um this is kind of an interesting thing
to think about to linger over
you know the ancients actually had camus
not talking about this but i think this
could illuminate it the ancients
actually had a argument for the
existence of god
which
it's been called by different forms i
like to call it the argument from
intelligence and it's a tell it's in
some ways
a
a cosmological argument another way it's
kind of a teleological argument
you could roll it into those but i think
it's actually distinctive and here's how
it goes
you see cicero talking about this you
see augustine in certain respects
talking about this
um we have intelligence
we don't fully understand intelligence
we're not totally transparent to
ourselves we're not totally
self-reflective but we are
intelligent and we know that there are
other things that lack intelligence and
as a matter of fact most of the universe
does seem to lack
some sort of intelligence it certainly
doesn't have the level of
self-reflectiveness
and
capacities that we have
if we want to say that a stone has a
certain amount of intelligence because
it knows to go down when we drop it
that's fine but that's nowhere near the
level of a dog nowhere near the level of
human being
where did that come from
can you get a greater
thing
from a lesser cause
if you begin from the postulate that no
a greater thing cannot come from the
lesser thing
then you're never going to get
intelligence from random things being
put together in certain ways or from
evolution or from you know pick whatever
mechanism you like
any mechanism
that begins with a raw brute material
things
that don't contain intelligence or have
very low levels of intelligence this is
not going to give you human intelligence
so therefore according to this proof
there must be intelligent beings
of greater intelligence than us who are
responsible for the very intelligence
that we have
come who's rejecting that
uh and really you know a lot of modern
culture has rejected that hasn't it i
mean that's why the theory of evolution
uh in all the different forms that it's
taken and it's taken a lot of different
forms over time not all of which are
compatible with each other
um that's why you can
you can say it could provide any
solution you have to reject the idea
that
that a greater cause a greater effect
can only come from a
a greater effect cannot come from a
lesser cause
if you reject that then you can do
evolution
if you don't reject that then you can't
um
so if you do reject that as kamuru does
think about this where do deeds where do
thoughts come from they often come from
very very tiny random
absurd
beginnings
great historical events
quite often come from just a bunch of
little causes coming together in some
weird way and then suddenly something
happens and we all say oh it's so
wonderful
he also talks about another case the
rhythm of unthinking unnoticing life
getting disrupted or seen through as he
says one day the why arises and
everything begins in that weariness
tinged with amazement that's a beautiful
line
weariness tinged with amazement because
you're already in the situation and
you've already been working and
enduring for a while before
the veil lifts
um another possibility suddenly
realizing one's place or point in time
he gives the example of being 30. and
you know if you realize that you're 30
especially in our culture where 30 is
the new 20 and 40 is the new 30 and when
people say that sort of stuff
that'd be a good thing he talks about
feeling your sense of youthfulness but
if you realize that you're 30
you realize that you're on a continuum
and okay you're still closer to this end
but
you're moving this way
and here's where you die
and it might be way over here at 80 or
it might be
right here at 30 and a day
so you become conscious of your
your point in temporarily the fact that
temporality is irreversible that can
help that can promote this sense of
absurdity right the natural world
he says take a step lower and
strangeness creeps in
perceiving that the world is dense
sensing to what degree a stone
is foreign and irreducible to us
anything that you pick even in this
human
technologized world you know an iphone
of sharpie marker paper
these are all physical objects and they
can suddenly lose their familiarity to
us they're
being and mixed in
frameworks of purposes and designs and
all that and they can stand out in their
brood facticity to us and then they can
start to make us feel the absurd
it says at the heart of all beauty lies
something inhuman he's talking about
landscapes
following that that thought he says the
primitive hostility of the world rises
up to face us across millennia for a
second we cease to understand it because
for centuries we've understood it and
solely the images and designs we've
attributed to it beforehand
henceforth we lack the power to make use
of that artifice
the world evades us
why
because it becomes itself again it
becomes what it truly is it stands forth
in its being against us in our existence
he says that denseness and strangeness
of the world
is the absurd
what about the humans
our world is a humanized world isn't it
that should make it not absurd anymore
right
well
yes and no
he says men to secrete the inhuman
at certain moments of lucidity the
mechanical aspect of their gestures
their meaningless pantomime makes silly
everything that surrounds them and you
know there's movies in which there are
scenes where this sort of thing is is
being depicted and it's not really being
said necessarily with a voiceover
suddenly i realized how absurd
everything was but you see
for instance somebody talking to another
person
and the second person
one way of depicting this is the first
person you you're looking through the
second person's eyes and you see their
lips moving and suddenly there's like
wha
and what they're saying doesn't matter
anymore it's it's become absurd
where they're doing things and what
they're doing doesn't make any sense
well that is another encounter with the
absurd
finally death
our own death not just that of others i
mean that of others can can make the
world seem pretty absurd too the death
of uh one's one's loved
uh spouse or you know
even worse i suppose would be a fiancee
you know you're about to get married and
they get hit by the boss
what kind of universe is this
you know that would be a sense of the
absurdity thinking about your own death
he says in reality there's no experience
of death properly speaking nothing has
been experienced but what has been lived
and made conscious here it's barely
possible to speak of the experience of
others deaths
it's a substitute an illusion and it
never quite convinces convinces us that
melancholy convention cannot be
persuasive
the horror comes in reality from the
mathematical aspect of the event
if time frightens us
this is because it works out the problem
and the solution comes afterwards
all the pretty speeches about the soul
will have their contrary convincingly
proved at least for a time
from the this inert body on which a slap
makes no mark the soul has disappeared
this elementary and definitive aspect of
the adventure constitutes the absurd
feeling
under the fatal lighting of that destiny
its uselessness becomes absurd that
becomes evident
no code of ethics no effort or
justifiable a priori in the face of the
cruel mathematics that command our
condition
so the fact that we're going to die
inevitable
and yet we can't make even sense on what
is it to die
and we can't even make sense of it by
looking at other dead people i mean most
of us in today's
uh very sanitized
modern western liberal democratic
society have very little contact with
with
dead people and dying people they've
been shunted off for the most part
we go to funerals every once in a while
but we don't actually
see people in the process of dying too
often those who do
know a hell of a lot more about it than
those who don't
you know
and those who do are actually
in touch with something
that
99 of the people throughout the history
of the world had to
encounter share make sense out of as
much as they could
in ways that that people living in
sanitized society don't
i think something's actually lost by
that and i'm speaking of somebody who's
had a lot of contact with death myself
so
but not as much as many other people i
know
so
where can we encounter the absurd the
absurd can papa anywhere at any time
how can we encounter it well we can
encounter it in terms of
everyday life
anywhere you look
these grand themes like
death itself
human beings the natural world
even the encounter with beauty
we can also encounter it in the life of
the mind we can also encounter it in the
way that we live
we can also encounter it in
art
and you know art covers a lot of ground
especially again in our society
perhaps even more ground than it does
in caimus time you know when you have
film music
all the plastic art sculpture painting
you have dance you have plays kamu
actually himself role plays you have
novels he wrote novels
what do we have we have way more music
that we can play at any time that we
want on demand some of the music that we
have is actually sampled music using
previous music not just sort of
replicating it through talentry but just
copying it
we have
films
everywhere you can watch them on youtube
if you want you i mean you can actually
produce your own cartoons if you like
using say extra normal or a few other
services like that
we have televisions just about
everywhere
[Music]
we actually do have quite a few nice
landscapes
you can probably have access to
reproductions of artists works way more
than any time in history so if you want
you know monet
on your laptop is your your you know
wallpaper you can you can do that
[Music]
getting to see plays
that's about the same level as it was
before but but these other things you
know artistic production and artistic
consumption that's one way in which we
can understand what's going on with the
absurd
so i'm not going to go into any of these
three in great detail or depth in this
particular
installment
of the discussion of this this essay
what i'm going to do is next time i'm
going to talk in great
detail about the life of the mind
and about the existentialists in
particular and camus complained about
them i'm going to talk about that in
just a minute
in general and tell you a little bit
about some of the people that he's he's
bringing up because you may not be
familiar with them
we'll talk about a bit of the art of
living in that case and then we'll talk
and then in the next installment we'll
talk very
much about the
issue of artistic production and we'll
also talk about the myth of synthesis
himself and what he represents
um
so let's think about this a little bit
broad terms
what i want to leave you with on this
particular installment is this
i put this up before
these represent three possible sets of
responses
and if you had to put them in terms of
like percentages this would be
most people this would be
a few and this would be something
you know
novel or
new i i don't think that camus
believes that he is the only person to
put forward his kind of
way of living i think that
if you look at the rest of his work
he sees other people as living this life
of the absurd
as he puts it
living without making the leap without
buying into something
another way that he puts it
much later on
is
being able to live
without appeal
by that being willing to live in a world
that at bottom
turns out to be absurd
without trying to smuggle in something
else from the outside to
make it make sense
and there's a possibility of solidarity
on the basis of that
well let's talk about this for for a
moment
so we say rationalists
if you you know if you had an intro to
philosophy class you may have
encountered the term rationalists
in terms of the the continental
rationalists versus the british
empiricists during the history of
philosophy and descartes spinoza leibniz
uh locke barkley hume you had to
memorize those and okay there is some
some uh
some truth to that they they're these
people did call themselves rationalists
but for french philosophers rationalists
has a much broader connotation than
merely you know the people who believed
in innate ideas as opposed to those who
believed in experience from the french
perspective that camus is working with
waddles and purists are highly
rationalists themselves here's why what
is a rationalist believe the world is
ultimately able to be made sense out of
and they perhaps even fixed made better
through reason
reason
is the human way the distinctively human
way of apprehending the world of
relating to other people of
understanding the self and if you
believe in a god of relating to god
a rationalist believes in the power the
capacity of reason
they may not call it reason they may
call it common sense they may call it
by the name of a particular ideology but
they have some set of beliefs
some beginning points and some processes
of inference that will allow them to
make sense out of all of this stuff more
or less or the things that don't make
sense at least to say well you know
those those don't matter that much we
can brush those off sweep those under
the rug the stuff that really matters
the stuff that we're concerned with that
all makes sense that can all be
understood we may not even understand it
all right right now but we're committed
to the view that someday it can be
understood so the scientific process
itself those who are committed to
science those who view technology itself
is something that will you know
ultimately make life better and better
and better
and not produce catastrophe
you know in the process they are
rationalists
you could be a rationalist in a very
debased sense
if your idea
is that the world can be divided up into
you know republicans and democrats and
then the gutless people in between uh
and you know one of these is good and
one of these is bad and they're
diametrically opposed you're a
rationalist
by camus view
and if you have something like that
those who are watching this in other
countries pick whatever party analogs
you like
that would make you a rationalist
most communists would actually be
rationalists from kamu's perspective
most
people on the far right would be
rationalists
from his perspective
so
the rationalist is devoted to this
notion that the world makes sense it may
not be fair
it may not be
entirely arranged the way it ought to be
and take some work
but it ultimately does make sense
and
that's to ultimately try to push away
the absurd
now
that might not be
the way a person truly feels
but there are people who go on like this
um
what's another possibility well you know
the existentialist that he does talk
about who are these extensions let me
put this on
who are the existentialists that can
move
connect to in this piece
he brings up
of course kierkegaard
he mentions
he mentions nietzsche
so far so good i mean these are the
three
granddaddies of existentialism before
it's called existentialism aren't they
he mentions
gospels
he mentions kierkegaard
he mentions uh
height here
anybody else that he mentions yeah
there's a very important guy who often
gets left out
great russian thinker
who immigrated to france
uh shestop
leon chef stop
of these are existentialist thinkers and
he does talk about a few other people as
well
again he talks about shaler
talks about
husserl these are phenomenologists
heidegger is also a phenomenologist he
heidegger
heidegger husserl and shaler are the
great three early phenomenologists you
know there were other phenomenologists
but these are the three you know biggest
names
now
camus is not criticizing nietzsche for
this so much so we give ninja pass right
but the rest of these people he's not
really talking that much about those
stansky the rest of these people
he thinks that what they're doing
they're pointing out the fact that no
you know you can't actually begin with a
world that ultimately makes sense and
just you know start out with
postulates that you're going to
introduce and you know
make it fit and and all of that sort of
stuff
the world doesn't admit that anymore
there's a divorce and we're actually
going to finish with that when i can
get us to that point
these existentialists are aware of the
fact that the world is absurd
that man is absurd
that the connection between the human
being and the world is absurd that the
connections between human beings and
themselves are absurd
that the absurd can pop out at any
moment he actually talks about heidegger
and and the anxiety in that sense he
talks about chest off
sort of you know undoing rationalism at
every every respect in that response and
bringing in nietzsche and dostoyevsky in
order to do so he talks about
kierkegaard as himself being committed
to this
but he sees this as a failure of nerve
he sees them as all
making what he calls the leap of jumping
saying that yeah okay the world is
absurd and it doesn't have any meaning
and that's why it has to have a meaning
and that meaning is
god
or
you know transcendence in the case of
gospels or
something god knows what in the case of
heidegger or you know you can keep going
on up perhaps even you know the uber
match for vernicha
so
if you do
that you're acknowledging the absurd
and you're lingering with it for a while
but then you're leaving it behind you're
not
fully being consequent to it that's the
camus view
that's the view of what he calls the
existentials
well with the absurd
what goes on with that
what is actually
taking place
he says that there's a divorce
involved in the absurd
and this is this is a good place to sort
of sum things up and bring them to a
kind of close
we have the human being
and the human being what can we say
about the human being human being is
conscious
human being has desires
you're not just a brain you're not just
a mind
your mind and your your brain are
motivated by by desires
are these desires simply things like
eat drink sleep have sex
you have a desire for transcendence you
have a desire for meaning
you have a hunger
and affection
the nostalgia he says for unity
for things making sense being brought
together
that's why the rationalist point of view
is so strong that's why it works itself
that's why it attracted people
um what else
where do you exist
you exist in the world
and the world includes you
you are an object in the world
the world includes other human beings
but it also includes so much else
and
the world itself is
ultimately
irrational which means this it doesn't
mean that it doesn't have any reason
whatsoever
it's that reason
comes to stops
fails
doesn't
fully work
apply there are different ways we can we
can talk about this
but say that the world is irrational
means that you can explore it to some
degree with reason and you can you know
with instrumental reason you can
form things to make technology
incredibly advanced technology like this
you can make things work the way you
want in limited areas
but ultimately
you don't control time and you don't
control space even very much or its
conditions and you don't control
causality very much you can really
understand it that well
and once you start introducing other
human beings and their purposes and
accidents and things like that it gets
very very muddy and very murky and then
to start introducing you know other
living beings oh wow it's
reason is going to grasp all of that
the human being is rational and wants to
make things rational the human being has
a desire
for the rational
and there is this sort of
divorce
between the human being
and the absurd
encompasses
this whole complex
it includes the human being
it includes the world
and it includes the divorce between the
two
the absurd is
something that that exceeds
all of these and brings them together he
says the absurd depends as much on man
as on the world
i said the world is absurd but i was too
hasty the world itself is not reasonable
but that's all that can be said what is
absurd is the confrontation of this
irrational
and the wild longing for clarity whose
call echoes in the human heart
this binding together
of the
wanting so badly
for things to make sense to work out
a human
being and a world that
you know
may admit that to a certain extent but
for the most part doesn't care and you
know is going to
it's not actually going to try to you
know screw you over or controvert you
it's just not going to fit that that
thing
that decision that that
rupture that that incommensurability
between the two
that is the absurd
so we've gone a long way so far we
haven't actually answered the question
of should you kill yourself or not come
who's going to say no so don't anybody
uh watch this and then do that
we haven't yet started exploring these
different domains in which absurdity
takes place and we're not looking yet at
the solution that kamu brings but first
we had to set the problem out in its
full
light next we're going to look at the
the intellectual life and then we're
going to look at you know ethics and
action and then we're going to look at
artistic production and then we're
finally going to get to talk about this
guy synthesis rolling the boulder up the
hill only to have it fall all the way
down to the other side then picking it
back up and rolling it up and going all
the way back down the central metaphor
for this synthesis is the absurd man
symphysis is the representative of camus
ethic
and so that is where we're going to
ultimately head